[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without hello everybody
welcome to the minimalists podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and oh
boy what a month it has been Ryan and I
and our fearless producer Sean Harding
we've been on the road for the last five
weeks or so taking our film which is
called minimalism a documentary about
the important things all over the
continent and we are finally back here
in beautiful Missoula Montana and today
we're gonna bring to you one of our live
events you see whenever we go to one of
these cities we try to experience a
little bit of the city even though we're
there for only a few days so we'll find
some great coffee in in dallas-fort
Worth area
it was Kraftwerk coffee we'll find a
great museum we went to the Museum of
Modern Art there and Fort Worth and my
god it was it was the most beautiful
building that I think I've ever seen it
was just amazing we also went to the
spiral diner but we got there right as
they were closing so we're gonna have to
save that until next time and of course
after we experienced the city we really
get to experience the city because we
get to hug hundreds of people who come
to our events and in Dallas we got to
interact with a bunch of you and after
we screened the film we brought a bag of
answers and we answered your questions
and so in today's episode of the podcast
we're going to present to you that live
event in Dallas but before we do just a
couple of quick updates new over at the
blog at the minimalists comm slash wow
that's wo w wow there's a bunch of
updates about the film the film itself
is the the number one film of 2016 so
far and we give you some details about
that and really just want to say thank
you for all of your support and everyone
who's sharing it but also the
and theatrical release is tomorrow June
8th we have a bunch of details there
the Australian release coming really
soon some details on that but if you're
not in those countries let's say you're
in the UK or you're in Brazil or
somewhere else
we also have some details for you over
at that blog post that talks about how
you can get a private or a public
screening license so you can show that
film in your local theatre you're a
local yoga studio or even your living
room with a bunch of friends and also we
have the online release of the film
August 2nd but if you preorder the film
over at Vimeo which actually just go to
our website the minimalists comm slash
order you get six hours of bonus content
with that the film is of course still in
the US theaters as well throughout the
summer limited release there all the
details on that at minimalism film comm
we also just posted the soundtrack to
the film and there's a bunch of reviews
in that blog post that I mentioned that
blog post is simply titled a bunch of
exciting updates about the minimalism
documentary also a quick second update
here I have a Writing Workshop that I
teach a few times a year it's just a a
one day online Writing Workshop it's a
radically attenuated version of my
four-week class
you see I teach a an a long online class
that's four weeks and I require a whole
lot out of my students so there's a lot
of effort a lot of drudging through the
drudgery and I expect a lot out of the
students in that class and so I tend to
estrange I tend to talk people out of
taking that class because of the amount
of work that it requires not because
writing is inherently difficult but
putting in the effort on a repeated
basis is difficult for a lot of people
and so not everyone has the time money
resources whatever to dedicate to a
month-long class but most people are
still looking for best practices or tips
and tricks on how to improve your
writing so I teach a one day workshop if
you're interested in that or if you're
interested in the the four-week class
you can go to how to write better org
that workshop is later this month it is
limited seating but there are still some
seats left so feel free to stop over at
how to write better org and check that
out if you're trying to figure out how
to improve your writing now I want to
present to you I hope you enjoy this
live version of the minimalists podcast
in Dallas
well hello Dallas welcome to a live
version wow thank you welcome to a live
version of the minimalist podcast I'm
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and that makes us the
minimalist and we're here in Dallas
after everyone just got to see the
Dallas premiere of minimalism a
documentary about the important things
and we're going to take some questions
from the audience you can ask whatever
you want I have a my favorite
pedagogical technique is if I don't have
the answer to your question I will just
answer a different question so you can
ask whatever you want we have a bag of
answers up here you will get one of them
tonight just go ahead and say your name
and just speaking of the mic say your
name and whatever your question is and
thank you so much for coming my question
is is there going to be sometime in the
future well I will be able to sit around
and add value with showing this to a
bunch of my friends and family again yes
absolutely so right now we're doing the
theatrical release of this there's a
couple things you can do here and I've
actually got some good news for everyone
here I don't think I've told the other
screens about this for whatever reason
but I'm gonna tell you all about it
tonight
so first off the movie comes out in
about 400 theaters across the United
States and Canada starting May 24th and
you can also request your own screening
as well if you don't have a screen at
your local theater you can just go to
minimalism film calm if you want to
invite a bunch of friends to a screening
you can do that in your local theater
but it'll also be available online
starting August 2nd
but anyone who pre-orders it online gets
six hours of like bonus interviews so
when we went out and did all these
interviews
and filmed all these sunsets and stuff
we have about a thousand hours of
content literally and we're gonna
provide six hours of bonus interviews as
well with that pre-order but also to all
every single theatrical screening that
sells out they get a that those six
hours emailed to them well this sold out
about two weeks ago I think maybe a week
or so ago so yeah you all get that for
free so the short answer is yes you will
definitely be able to to pass this on to
other people that was really the
intention we we know that not everyone
reads books anymore we know that not
everyone's gonna sell the read a blog or
get on Twitter or whatever we're
constantly finding those different
avenues those different routes to try to
communicate with people and we we knew
that a documentary would be another
another way that we communicate another
channel through which another device
that we had used to to spread this this
message of minimalism so yes not only
will it be available we would be really
grateful if you shared it with other
people because we hope they find value
in it my name is Deb I was on your
second podcast I absolutely love what
you guys have done and I talked about
how it's affected me and it's affected
my son he's 17 he's here in the audience
and it's just completely changed our
lives I've gotten rid of a lot probably
over 50% of my stuff last week I got rid
of my kitchen table because I just felt
like we just didn't need it anymore so
thank you thank you delicious
so it's an honor to be here in front of
you guys one of your podcasts you guys
had mentioned this type of library that
someone had set up where there were
things like tools right where people
could go and borrow certain things that
they needed just for a temporary time do
you do you remember that it was the
library that was set up people were
donating things or you knew of someone
that was starting one and I was just
wondering are there more that you know
of that are being started yeah there I
think you're talking about maybe the
Tool Library that we have in Missoula
Montana so you can basically go to this
this place where not only can you rent
tools but people donate like leftover
doors or wood or trim or whatever they
have and it's it's kind of cool because
it's like this mix match of like
beautiful stuff that people have just
given cuz they have have it left over
from their projects at home and yeah
certainly I've seen more of those pop up
there's a I think it's Toronto oh man I
have to double check that but uh it's
it's called this stuff store and it is
literally a library of stuff and they're
just curating whatever they can so you
can go there and borrow you know a
chainsaw or a bread maker it literally
has just the wide range of stuff that
you can check out I don't know of
anything specifically here in Dallas
yeah I don't know how many people here
use freecycle
but I'm assuming because it's a large
enough city you can just go to google
freecycle and and basically it's a
library of stuff even in Missoula we
have there's like a bicycle library I
guess you could call it if you walk past
it it looks like a bicycle graveyard
there's like 2,000 bicycle corpses just
laying there and it's where you can go
and assemble your own bike and and it's
free and and so I think we're constantly
or more and more we are moving from a
culture of ownership where we need to
own these new consumer goods and
constantly consume them so being able to
have access to those things so I'll put
this question out to you if any of you
know of a great app or anything or just
a local place that you can can either
donate and share yourself as a community
love that and also for the folks who are
listening to this at home and around the
world if you want to give us a call four
oh six two one nine seven eight three
nine they can leave tips on how to do
this as well what we found is that Ryan
and I don't have all the answers we have
about 12 answers and and the nice thing
is by having a large community of a few
million people though there tends to be
good answers out there so a lot of
people have shared a lot of great tips
on our podcast so we try to include
those voicemails at the end
it's minimalism tips from from our
listeners so hopefully someone here has
a recommendation on how to do free cycle
or something in your community because
they're going to be more familiar with
dallas-fort worth or some people might
call in you'll hear it on the podcast
later for sure thank you thank you
the first one is that the blatant
consumerism even within where I go for
inspiration it feels like they're trying
to sell me things to make me a better
minimalist and I feel like I can't get
away from and it just it seems like it's
all around and something I just can't
escape the second thing is the
superiority we watch these videos of
people running into Walmart and saying
oh I'm better than that that's not me
I'm not one of those people and I just
want to know how y'all operate through
minimalism with love and integrity
trying to not be superior or involved in
the consumers I'll take the consumerism
part no you know yeah it's very well
first off when you call yourselves the
minimalist it's like everything you do
become steeped in irony like this isn't
a very minimal crowd we don't sell very
minimal amount of books so forth and so
on
I mean for me I have to consume some
things I've got a buy some blue jeans
I've got to eat food there is a level of
consumption we all have to have and this
minimalism for me is about consuming
responsibly I would say that you know
everything that we have put out there I
mean you're not gonna see like the
minimalist toolkit from us we had an
April Fool's joke you know it's like a
500 dollar black t-shirt we were selling
or something which we surprised how many
people were like dude can I really get
this t-shirt it was crazy so we did math
on that by the way so it was April
Fool's joke this huge oh y'all see that
it was seven hundred and thank you well
if now I get the not everyone who
clicked the Buy Now button would have
actually purchased the seven hundred $29
but if they had it would have been over
six million dollars worth of people
buying a $700 and it was a Hanes t-shirt
by the way you could see the tag and the
the the the worst part was we got
several people who didn't get the joke
and they emailed us and said that where
is the actual purchase link and so what
I would say is I don't judge those
people identify with that that's that's
me that consumption is is who we were
yeah definitely um but yeah I mean
[Music]
anything that we that we have is is
something that we encourage you to pass
on anything we sell I should say we
encourage people to pass on donate to a
library I mean even our books we will
say hey grab a book but when you're done
with it minimize it give it to someone
who's gonna find value out of it or if
you don't want to have one or get one of
our books that's fine I'm sure they have
it at the local library there are there
are certainly ways to to consume
responsibly
and I think that's where we really need
to get to as a society I don't you know
that there is this the zero waste
community that's kind of sprouting right
now which i think is awesome I think
that is such an amazing and amazing
approach to living one's life even in
that situation they're still gonna be
you know someone come like we were down
in st. Pete Beach Florida at the coffee
shop that you probably heard us talk
about and gal came in with her mason jar
and she's like you know I'm zero waste
and I thought that was awesome she
brought a mason jar in like she's not
gonna have anyways but there's so much
waste that goes into making that coffee
so I don't think we're ever going to
eliminate needing to consume things I
mean that's how we live to get by but
there are certainly ways that we can do
it responsibly and I'll agree with you
that you talked about how there's a lot
of maybe consumption within minimalism
what I found is that it's become this
trendy marketing thing that now you go
to the gap or something and there's a
poster that just says minimalism and
there's like you know a half-naked
skinny person who is
is you know on this poster and it just
says minimalism and I'm like minimalism
isn't necessarily a product and it can
be an experience and that's why we write
books or or have a film or anything like
that we encourage people to have the
experience but then to move beyond the
experience and actually do something if
you if you've tweezed any sort of
nuggets out of that recipe so so
hopefully tonight and by the way we so
this is a great opportunity for me to to
pivot here we have books out there
afterward and what I'll tell you is
they're they're pay what you want if you
don't have if you can't afford one right
now we just encourage you to take one on
us let us buy it for you and and we want
for you to find some value in it and of
course minimize it afterward and
hopefully someone else will get value
from it as well and just a good year to
kind of do the the second question you
had to speak a little bit more to that
the the crowds in the beginning the the
Black Friday sales that was me that was
who I was and I wish that someone would
have shook me and helped me to see how
crazy it was to get into that mentality
and if anything that's what we're trying
to do is is trying to to relate through
our own experiences to show other people
that hey we were there we we totally
understand where that impulse comes from
but there are ways to curb that impulse
there are ways to still you know consume
in a responsible manner that isn't going
to kill off the earth thank you thank
you
paddy howdy hi I'm Jennifer I'm from
Fort Worth I'm the cow town minimalist
by the way yeah
also at Cowtown minimus
i still nothing my question for you guys
and I know you both speak to it and and
a lot of the folks you interviewed who I
know are big followers on Twitter of
yours they speak to minimalism to live
intentionally and I guess what I as
minimalist would like to do is do that
what does that mean to you and what do
you think that means to a lot of the
folks that you chose to interview I can
tell you what it means for me and I
could try to project that on to them but
but I think they would tell you best I
could tell you for me if I had match my
short-term actions with my long-term
values that's what living intentionally
is and that's going to lead to
longer-term contentment so I can tell
you for the longest time I would tell
people that my priorities were my health
my relationships what I was passionate
about my priority was to contribute to
my community I said these things but
those were just lip service priorities
my real priorities was how I was
spending my time so working 80 hours a
week that was a priority incessantly
checking email at 11:00 p.m. at night
and then five o'clock in the morning as
soon as I woke up that was my priority
my real priorities were getting on to
Facebook or or you're eating fast food
instead of being eating healthfully and
what I learned is that our priorities
are how we spend our time we don't all
have the same resources we're not born
in the same situation we don't have the
same careers the same IQs the same
emotional intelligence we all have the
same 24 hours in a day in our priorities
however we spend those 24 hours and so
now being intentional with my time
matching what I do today with the person
I want to be the person I want to become
the person I'm constantly aspiring to be
my 40 year old self I'm 34 years old now
and it's really about matching today's
actions with that ideal version of
myself
yeah and just to give you a you know an
example for what it means for me to live
intentionally a real-life example is I
have a 2004 Toyota Corolla it leaks when
it rains as much as I avoid magazines
and TV and commercials I still get like
car commercials shoved in my face
constantly and every time I see a new
car like there is a twinge like I wish I
could say to read all of our books and
you buy our minimalist packet but like
yeah you're never gonna crave to buy
anything again it just doesn't work that
way so I have to ask those important
questions like is this going to add
value to my life is this does this align
with my long-term values this is aligned
with my long-term beliefs so like the
car for example every time I get that
twinge like I really will sit there and
think like man I know I could probably
go out and get a loan for a couple
hundred bucks a month I could totally
afford that and have that you know
weighing on my shoulders for the next
you know three to six years depending on
what car I got and how long of a loan it
was but at the end of the day if I make
that decision to replace something that
really honestly doesn't need to be
replaced that is going to I'm going to
fall short of those values and beliefs
so again just going back to constantly
asking is this going to add value to my
life it does this align with my values
and beliefs that's what living
intentionally is for myself
this is my first time well this is this
is my first time watching your
documentary I just kind of heard about
you guys from one of my roommates but
watching your documentary I think I get
it
avoiding the pitfall of unconsciously
consuming or consuming without thought
impulsively but I was just curious I'd
like to hear you maybe more talk about
and you may have already answered my
question but just about the human
condition of being discontent what seems
to be like the root of the problem
because you can fix you know okay now
I'm going to consume intentionally and
mindfully and thinking about what I do
but after you get that down can you be
discontent with minimalism
yes impossible then you know you could
you could go home and rent a dumpster
and like throw everything away and I
promise you it's possible to be
completely miserable and sulk in an
empty apartment there's no doubt about
that I mean for me minimalism allowed me
to clear the clutter to make room for
life's most important things and what I
mean by that is my health
like when I when I was sitting there at
the end of my packing party since this
is your first time you don't know what
that is I'll tell you real quick so when
I first started down my minimalism path
I had a conversation with Josh and he
told me about this thing called
minimalism I'm like dude this sounds
awesome
what do I do now I don't I'm a
minimalist but what the heck do I do so
we decided to pack up everything in my
2,000 square foot condo as if I were
moving and then I would unpack things
day by day as I needed it to really get
a sense of what I was using so at the
end of these three weeks I had about 80%
of my stuff still sitting in boxes and
and that was like my real big lightbulb
moment cuz I was thinking to myself you
know health is something that has always
been
to me like I've always talked about it
and how I you know want to work out and
eat healthy and you know it would always
happen where I pick up a good diet for a
couple weeks or start a good workout
regimen for a couple weeks and then I'd
get busy and I would find excuses to
break that habit that I would try to
incorporate in my life and I'm looking
at all this stuff and I'm like man like
if I hadn't wasted so much time just
getting all of these accoutrements I
could have probably spent a little bit
more time following through with those
things or with my relationships I
thought about the my mom who lived a
half hour away my daddy lived about a
half hour away as well and how I saw her
maybe you know six seven times a year
major holidays Mother's Day her birthday
just rarely ever saw her and I always
told myself you know one day I'm gonna
have enough money I'm gonna have enough
stuff saved up I'm I'm gonna have a
perfect life for me and once I have that
perfect life when I'm 50 or whatever
that age comes maybe I retire early at
45 or 40 I'm gonna be able to spend all
the time I want with my mom but sitting
there with all that stuff I'm like wow
if I if I just could kind of eschew some
of this stuff and stop pursuing some of
this I could actually do that now I
don't have to wait another 10 20 30
years to do that so going back to the
decisions that I make aligning with my
short-term I'm sorry my short-term
decisions aligning with my long-term
values and beliefs like that was that
was a value for me spending quality time
with my mom and for me that's where the
discontent really sets in is when I keep
waking up every morning and I say one
day I'm gonna do this but right now I
got to push through this and sometimes
you got to do that sometimes you got to
make some sacrifices there's no doubt
about it but there are there's a certain
level of sacrifice that's too much and I
think that for me is where the
discontent settled in is when I was
sacrificing everything everyone to
pursue those those things yeah I would
say that discontent comes from pursuing
happiness
often people ask us like wow you guys
you've done the minimalism thing you
must be happy now right and I'm like
well yeah I'm happier than I've ever
been but happiness isn't the point you
see the problem was I was chasing
happiness throughout my my 20s and it
was always around the corner but then I
get around the corner and it wasn't
there and of course it was gonna be
around the next corner so I needed the
the new car you know I already had one
Lexus but I need a second Lexus I needed
a bigger house I needed a promotion
I needed the the trinkets the trophies
of success and once I got those of
course I was going to be happy but of
course that didn't happen the the closer
I got to happiness the farther away it
was and eventually what I figured out is
it was the pursuit of happiness that was
making me discontent and so the point is
in happiness the point is living a
meaningful life and then happiness
there's a really awesome byproduct of
that and so now if I'm living meaningful
you know our first book that we wrote
I'd love to give you a copy of it if
you're interested in having it
it's called minimalism live a meaningful
life we wrote about that the five
higher-order values of of living more
meaningfully and and it was what Ryan
and I identified with after the stuff so
the stuff was the initial bite at the
Apple that changed everything for us but
then it was like okay what do I focus on
my health
well I weighed 80 pounds more than I
weigh now my relationships I forsook
them so I didn't I didn't have my
closest friends closest to me I was
spending all my time with co-workers and
networking buddies and executives and
and and not with the people I care I
said I cared about and then what I was
passionate about I wasn't focused on
that I wasn't focused on growing I
wasn't focused on contributing to the
world and that's what a meaningful life
looks like to me now it's not about
chasing that next ephemeral indulgence
to make me happy so if afterward if you
or if you'd want to grab a book out
there a copy of minimalism
meaningful life I think you finds value
in it for sure thank you and if you guys
ever have time if you could make a
petition to help America like stop
working full time that would be great
yeah amen he was told today um my name
is Cheryl Collette
man that's southern accent thank you ten
and three they're known as the
itty-bitty foodies and they know you
guys as the guys who delete their stuff
every week after I listen to your
podcast
okay I'm happy to be the bad guy you can
blame it on us with anyone else in your
life if it makes it easier I was
wondering whether you had any tips on
how to reach little kids on how to live
you know it's really easy for ya real
easy for us to give advice well for me
because I'm have no kids just just throw
out all this stuff I don't know you know
I will I'll tell you I just give you one
example of a parent who came to one of
our events who shared with us kind of a
technique she's with her daughter a
little bit her daughter she basically
this question came up and usually I'm
like you know I will recommend other
people who are minimalist who have
children and that's kind of my answer
but she stood up and she was like you
know I I have an answer for this my my
little girl at home I hate to tell her
no I just hate telling her no so I will
say yes as often as I can
in the example she used was she will
come home with a an art piece you know
something she did at school and she'll
say hey mom you know look at this thing
I colored today can we please put this
on the refrigerator and her mom would
say yeah we can absolutely do that now
there's you know there's already art
covering the refrigerator
so there's really not room for it but
she'll say yeah we can totally do that
let's go over and pick which one you
want to take down and it's kind of this
one in one out rule that she has it's
the same thing with toys if you know she
goes her mom says hey um I really want
this toy and it's appropriate and they
can afford it so say yeah we can
absolutely do that what toy would which
toy would you like to donate and give to
a child who could really another child
who could really use this so I thought
that was a pretty cool pretty cool
approach I became a parent by proxy last
year I was just backstage facetiming
with my partner Becca and her two and a
half year old Ella and she was saying
hey Josh look what I have
a snake it was a piece of floss and and
you know I've learned so much over the
course of the last year or so with with
parenting and and what I've learned
ultimately is what was a big lesson in
here from Joshua Becker
our kids are watching us and you can
tell them something and until you're
blue in the face but they pick up on our
actions they pick up on the nuances it's
really hard to [ __ ] a two and a half
year old that they know what's up and
and so what I found is that they're
content with virtually nothing her and
Becca today spent the day gardening and
planting kale and in the garden and and
she was so happy and excited about that
but what I can tell you is they're a
bunch of resources out there
because I don't think any one person has
any magic answers but so Leo and Joshua
Becker are two great places to start if
you just go to the minimalists comm
slash children there's a book there from
Joshua Becker called clutter free with
kids and we asked Leo to write an essay
for us because you know he has six kids
and he is like he is minimalism
personified I mean he is like the ultra
minimalist and so he wrote an essay for
us called no excuses minimalism with six
kids and what I can tell you is I found
a lot of value in both those resources
and I think you would tell
thank you so much thank you thank you
hey guys I'm Matt and you're familiar
Matt we've met before yes we have
several times yes sir I just want to say
thank you so much for coming back to
Dallas and just so much stuff that I've
picked up on from you guys has helped me
in my life
addiction was the first thing and I've
incorporated minimalism in my life not
so much so that it that it's a new
addiction but it definitely has helped
me you know to focus on what really
matters and what's important for me and
Josh would I really incorporate you know
no labels on my clothing and no logos
and stuff like that and and that helps
me be conscious of what I'm purchasing
um the the questions that I have first
off we met and this was like for
probably four years ago went to eat
around the corner at a restaurant and
you posted on Twitter hey anybody that
wants to come join us and I was the only
one five years later there's 500 people
in this auditorium and did y'all see
this growing as big as it's gotten did
you ever see it getting this this huge
and also what city around the u.s. do
you think values minimalism or or or is
is more accepting or open to minimalism
if you've seen a city or a state that
embraces it more than another which part
do you want to take I'll take the first
part yeah it's it's funny because like
anytime I get asked about like is there
any city that stands out for X Y or Z
it's so hard to like just choose
anything so I'm gonna take the first
question
no we never thought getting this big it
was it was a really natural growth that
has happened over the last almost six
years now which I really appreciate cuz
like we've never really went viral it's
not like you know we were kind of
here and then all of a sudden boom you
know 500 people were showing up to our
events um it's and it's been it's just
been good that way because yeah it's
it's helped me gain practice to talk in
front of crowds and be able to you know
be a better public speaker and stuff but
no man I am really shocked honestly that
it's at this point but I'm really
grateful that I am able to share this
story and and have so many people find
value in it and and we will continue to
to explore different ways
somebody was it the Chicago Tribune
somebody called this thing a multimedia
project that that we were being
interviewed by and I was and I was like
man that is a perfect term for this like
this really is it's like a multimedia
project that is really affecting a lot
of people's lives so we will continue to
[Music]
do our podcast we will continue to do
some video in some form or fashion we
haven't really decided on exactly how
we're gonna do that but you know as long
as people are still showing up as long
as people are you know still coming up
to us we're riding in and saying man you
have totally changed my perspective on
life and have really helped me gain
control we will continue to do this and
believe hopefully we can reach more more
people and help more folks in terms of
cities I think it depends on the
individual you know we both moved to
Missoula Montana toward the end of 2012
so when we met we still have been in
Dayton Ohio
[Music]
Ryan and I did and I can tell you the
temperament there is very in line with
with our values in fact we go out there
and it's like you're preaching to the
choir in Missoula Montana everyone's
like well yeah that's what you do
minimalism like that's that's the thing
and and and I didn't know what had a
label and but I also think that a big
city a place like like Los Angeles is
actually a great place for a minimalist
as well and and I realized that during
the filming of this because after
talking to so many people as I talked
about earlier we're shifting from a
culture of ownership to a culture of
access well cities big cities particular
have shared resources and so you have
access to more
when you're in a large environment so it
depends on what you like and what you
need access to see I I don't snowboard
but Ryan loves snowboarding and so he
has access to that within you know
within an hour of where we live there's
a hour and a half there's five different
places he can go and and snowboard and
and so having access to that is
important to him he doesn't have to own
the mountain in order to snowboard on it
and so being in a city gives you access
to amenities that you may have not
otherwise had and in a place like
Missoula Montana
so I think it depends on on your
personal preference what you're looking
for thanks so much guys and happy
Mother's Day to all the moms out there I
saw a lot of moms stuff in there and I
was like well nice Mother's Day mom
great thank you thanks Matt thanks Matt
hey guys my name is Philip I'm just
really grateful that you guys are here
in person it's really cool after
following you guys for you to be here
I've been on a minimalism journey for a
long time and for my whole life I feel
like I've been an avid consumer of
information and so like a lot of my time
is spent reading about social issues or
political issues or science or education
and I think all these things they help
me be a better citizen and they add
value to my life but the problem is that
there I I never feel like I can be
informed enough or enlightened enough
because there's just too much
information like I literally have
hundreds of tabs open on my phone right
now of articles I'd like to read but
there's just not time to get to them all
and so I guess my question is how do I
come how does someone come to terms with
that and still feel like they're growing
in and becoming more of the person that
they want to be I would challenge you to
close every single one of those tabs
after this but well I mean the reason
why I say that it's because you're right
man we are overloaded with information
the the what you brought up specifically
about the articles I used to be the same
way so I used to have and I do to an
extent I used to have this miscellaneous
folder
my web browser that I would like put
articles in that one read later and then
what I found was exactly what you're
dealing with
and there was one day where I was like
I'm just gonna delete it all I have no
idea what's in there I'm not gonna start
filtering through it cuz I know I'm
gonna be like oh well no I'll keep that
one I'll keep that one but the fact was
is I hadn't looked at any of those in
months and that's kind of how I look at
it now now what I do is I will bring an
article down instead of putting it in a
folder I will put it on the actual
shortcut menu so if that shortcut menu
is full I will either and I want to
bring something else down I will either
read what's in that shortcut menu or I
will be like no this is more important
than that and I'll totally district yeah
disregard it so all the information that
you have pulled open your browsers right
now I promise you you will come across
the majority of that information again
at some time but that's one way that I
help prioritize all that stuff at first
I put some fairly draconian rules in
place to deal with that because I also
had that fear of missing out actually
I'm gonna give you copy as be a shorter
answer I'll give you a copy of our book
essential because there's a whole tech
there's a whole technology chapter in
there one of the essays that's in there
is one of my favorites called most
emergencies aren't the problem is we
start treating everything like
emergencies now and to the point where
we can't discern what an actual
emergency is versus what a just a twitch
is in fact my friend Julian Smith he
wrote a book called the flinch and it's
about how we have this this biological
imperative someone swings a fist at us
we're gonna flinch we're gonna tense up
we're supposed to we're protecting
ourselves but now we we flinch at things
like a 1% drop in our for a 401 K over
the last quarter and we're flinching for
all of these things that don't require a
flinch and so we're overwhelmed by
anxiety because of it and so I found
that one of the things that was really
overwhelming me was by technology and so
I found ways to take back control of
that technology by putting in some rules
in place temporarily depriving myself of
things and then bringing the tools back
into my life in a way that was more
intentional by temporarily
removing it so I'd love to give you a
copy of essential afterward and I think
I think you'll find some value on that I
promise you man if you if you close all
hundred of those tabs out you are gonna
feel so much better man so I just want
to give you a little encouragement we'll
be checking your phone afterward during
the hugs thanks a lot
I feel like an impostor when I'm in a
group like this because I am I'm an
aspirational first step I have been I
have been working for three years
I've done the minimalist game for eight
months for eight full months I still
eight months in a row well not in a row
but you know so I've gotten rid of
thousands of things and I still have a
lot to go and so my question is I just
wonder sometimes like when I'm in a
group like this I don't feel like I
deserve to be here and I wonder show of
hands how many people are minimalist and
how many people just want to be you know
how many people are there so raise your
hand if you are a minimalist or if you
want to be a minimalist ready go see
it's everyone you're part of the group
you belong here well first I want to
commend you on on doing the the things
you have already done playing the men's
game over the past eight months and
getting it is absolutely is
I mean minimalism is not easy I mean you
heard me say it at the end there and I
think it's too often you know we hear
the word simple and we think that that
is synonymous with easy and simple is
not necessarily easy so that's why I
want to commend you because what you've
done is is a lot of hard work taking
those steps really you know well first
off I'll tell you I wasn't a minimalist
until I said I was I mean there was no
magic okay all right Josh am i
officially minimalist now I had my
packing party and got rid of 80% of my
stuff here's your certificate
for sale out in the lobby I'm getting
but but but yeah I mean what you're
doing right now
you're absolutely living in line with
that philosophy what I would encourage
you to do is to keep doing that I would
encourage you to keep keep getting rid
of thousands of things keep playing the
men's game if you want to you know find
some support there is a minimalist org
group that gets together all the time
and Dallas actually Mindy's here from
the the group yeah she's back there so
there was like nine of them that meant
before the movie before the movie and
they just you know kind of sat and
talked with each other and they support
each other there's no agenda there's
it's not like you go there like okay you
know Josh and Ryan sent us these topics
to discuss it's not like that it's it
really his to go there and and and to
support and to be supported so I would
encourage you to find people who who
encourage you and to surround yourself
with really awesome people
but even if you if you if you don't do
that and you just continue to play the
men's game you I promise you one day you
will look around and you will go oh my
god where'd all my stuff go yeah I would
I would definitely encourage you to to
find supportive people that helped to
helped me raise my standards and by
raising my standards I improved my life
significantly and so I think the
minimalist or group and many will be out
there after afterward with will be over
at a table giving out hugs and stuff
yeah well I mean they might be willing
to meet halfway or something at some
point
what's halfway Arlington I don't know I
don't know the DG ography here Houston
is that halfway
no we were in we were in Fort Worth
earlier today and yeah so I know it's a
bit of a drive but I'll tell you this
finding people who are gonna be
supportive even if it's online so
joining the minimalist org meetup group
we when we were on tour in 2014 part of
which you saw there we went to a hundred
different cities in eight different
countries and we left behind these free
local meetup groups in a hundred cities
just with the hopes that we could
connect people we don't want anything
from you it doesn't require an email
address or anything from you we just
want to leave that behind so you can
connect with open minded supportive
people and even if that isn't connecting
in person all the time there's this
group that's constantly online on
Facebook that you can you can connect
with those people and and support each
other virtually yes so just to kind of
reiterate if you go to minimal subtle or
you can click on the Dallas and then you
go to the Facebook page there's also an
online City Facebook page that you can
join and in both of those I mean there's
people just like you who are playing the
men's game and they're posting pictures
of things are getting rid of and it is
really kind of cool to see this
community of people especially in the
online city people who have never met
each other in real life but they go on
there and they're they're totally there
to encourage and support and and to be
supported
one last thing I'm not in favor of
organizing I think organizing sucks I
had a very organized life I had a very
organized life but I was a well
organized order organizing was a way for
me to just hide my my clutter but I
might encourage you to find a
professional organizer because
professional organizers know that the
easiest way for you to organize your
stuff is to get rid of most of it
so maybe find a local professional
organizer I bet you there's even one
that attends the the minimalist or group
at some point thank you thank you thank
you
howdy hi I'm Lacey I just wanted to tell
you quickly I came to one of your first
tours I I almost came I came to see you
guys at a little coffee shop in Mesa
Arizona I was in school at ASU
and I didn't come in I came to the
parking lot and I was like I want to
talk about minimalism with those guys so
bad but Ryan Nicodemus is so cute that
I'm too nervous to go in there I told
her to say that to talk to you guys my
question is a little bit about parenting
too but more about relationships I know
that's really important to you guys I
have three small children and I teach
them a lot and we do talking about
consumerism and consuming and every time
we buy something we're like you know
where did this come from like who made
this how much did they get paid stuff
like that but I have a huge extended
family and every time my kids go
somewhere with Grandma and Grandpa they
come home and they're like we got
shopkins and cards and we'd have to talk
about any of it it was great and it
hurts my feelings so I guess what I'm
asking is what's a way is there way that
you guys have been able to talk to
friends and family about what you're
doing and what it what minimalism is
about without damaging the relationship
yeah so so here's the thing about gifts
it's a sensitive subject the closer you
get to the the holiday or gift-giving
occasion right the problem is we wait
until Thanksgiving to start trying to
set expectations about Christmas gifts
it is May 8th today it's already
starting to become too late to start
talking about Christmas that's how soon
you need to start talking about
Christmas with your friends and family
it's really about setting expectations
and I found that that if I set my
expectations well in advance and
frequently enough but it's not just
about telling people what I don't want
what I don't want isn't interesting I
talked to them about what I do want
give me an experience or if you want to
give me a physical thing give me a
consumable great bag of coffee or bottle
of wine something that that I can enjoy
with you and Jen
something that I can experience whether
it's a concert or we're just gonna go
watch a sunset together whatever it may
be I found that if I set that
expectation well in advance and
frequently people are more open to it
because why do people give you gifts in
the first place they want you to be
happy they want to communicate their
love for you right that we've been told
that gift-giving is a love language yeah
it's like saying Pig Latin is a Romance
language the truth is people were trying
to the act itself of gift-giving is
meaningful the physical artifact itself
there's no meaning in that thing here's
a shiny widget here's about how much I
care about you I've also found that when
I'd like to give gifts I will do so on
non-obligatory
days so today is Mother's Day and so
people are gonna give each other gifts
fine
but isn't it much more meaningful if you
were to say hey it's April 23rd here's
this thing I thought you'd find a lot of
value in it but what is today is it
Mother's Day no no it's not a special
day other than every day is special
because you're in my life and I care
about you and I thought you'd find value
in this and I think if you do that and
communicate it frequently it's about
changing the behavior over over a long
time not not an instant flip of a switch
um yeah I mean I instantly think of my
mom who like called me up a month after
the website was was launched and she was
like hey how's it going I'm like it's
going great how are you and she's like
we're doing well what's this minimalist
crap
I was like oh you found the website cuz
like we hadn't told anyone she had must
have been googling my name or something
too to come across it and I'm like oh
yeah you found this site awesome what do
you think and she's like I really don't
know what to make of it like are you
depressed are you are you not gonna be
around for holidays anymore can I still
buy you stuff and I'm like well mom yes
I am depressed actually and yeah I'm
really in a rut and I need to get out of
it and what I've been doing the last you
know several years of my life isn't
working and I'm trying a different
approach I said but you know when it
comes to holidays of course I'm gonna be
around for holidays in fact I hope to be
around more than than just the holidays
I hope to be around more for just your
birthday and Mother's Day I really hope
that I can really foster a better
relationship between us and when it
comes to buying me stuff like yeah I
would really appreciate it if you
wouldn't get me anything and she was
like well I'm really glad that you're
changing your life but I'm still gonna
get you stuff cuz I'm your mother oh my
god guys suppose she has that right so I
explained to her like well mom if you
get me something I'm gonna have to you
know really really determine whether or
not I need it and if I don't need it if
it's not something that adds value and
when I say adds value I'm talking about
you know does it bring me joy
it does it serve a purpose if it's
something that I can't use in my life if
it doesn't fit in my life I'm gonna have
to give it away to someone whose life it
does fit into or I'm gonna donate it
which don't tell your mom that that's a
horrible thing to say to your mother
yeah so so eventually you know after she
got done yelling at me for giving her
that that answer I just eventually kind
of calmed her down and I'm like mom I
love you you love me right she's like
yes of course I love you I'm like I I
want you to be happy you want me to be
happy too right she's like yeah of
course I want you to be happy I said
well if that's the case then I don't
need you to have a packing party I don't
need you to call yourself a minimalist
you don't have to clean your house
before I come over and make sure
everything's nice and tidy like
not gonna come to your home and judge
anything I mean this journey is about me
trying to get out of this rut and in all
I need from you is support that's it
and that's what really kind of got
through to her and really made her kind
of change your heart a little bit
and she still bought me stuff like don't
don't get me wrong in fact she visited
me my girlfriend last February she came
out to stay with us and like we pick her
up from the airport she brings her
suitcase in to the apartment she opens
it up and like the first thing she pulls
out is like this
owl vase and like a couple of candle
holders the first thing I thought was
like trip to Goodwill that's fine a
couple weeks ago but you know before I
could really process that thought she
she said to me you know I know that you
have really been changing your life over
the last four years and I can see that
and I'm really really proud of you and I
love that you and Mariah flew me out
here and that you're letting me stay in
your apartment and I know you just got
this place and I just really wanted to
show you a token of my appreciation to
let you know how proud I am of you and
and give you these gifts but I do
understand that if this doesn't fit into
your home that you are gonna probably
donate it or you know find someone who
can use it it took her four years to get
to that point before she before she was
able to say that to me so I guess you
know what I would encourage you to do is
is to have to have a similar
conversation with friends and family who
you know who do love you and do want you
to be happy and if and if that is the
case I mean they should be willing to
support you in some some form or fashion
but keep living by example keep keep up
the good work and I know that they will
see that and they will eventually come
around if they love you one and want to
see you happy I'm sure they will
eventually come around a little lady I
see teachers at my school and they
always throw away things that I think
that they can use for stuff and like I
have a bunch of trash that I like take
it and use for stuff
and like I was wondering if there's like
any way that I could give you things for
people that actually need them or like
that can find a purpose in them so the
question is really I would just rephrase
it a little bit here and say so I don't
know if all of you heard that but but
sometimes our teachers throw out things
that could probably reuse repurposed
elsewhere as opposed to going to just
fill up a landfill and I don't know what
local organizations there are here we
have several in our local community in
Montana there's a place called donation
warehouse but there's a website that
curates a bunch of donation places all
over the country
it's called donation town org and I
would definitely recommend trying that
out if you know of resources or
materials that can be used elsewhere and
you can help people not throw the stuff
out then I think donation town org is a
great place to do a lot of these place
will actually come and pick up those
those items so that you don't have to
deal with it yeah I certainly agree I
mean I my first thought when I have
something that I can't use anymore or
[Music]
yeah it's it's I just you know have it
used in the last six months or something
I'm like wow I'm not gonna use that in
the next six months I need to get rid of
that my first thought isn't I'm gonna
throw this away my first thought is okay
can I donate this if it's like a
valuable item I can't think it last time
I did this besides my packing party a
few years ago I would you know maybe try
and sell it on Craigslist find someone
else who is looking for that item who
can you know get it at a cheaper cost
but yeah I would I would certainly agree
with that that there are ways to reuse
reuse items instead of just throwing
them out thank you thank you
how's it going fellas
outstanding he's doing I'm Paul and
[Music]
I wanted to know if you guys would like
to hear a joke yes how many minimalists
does it take to screw in a light bulb
wait was that the joke really yeah oh my
I was set up read my mind here you read
my mind here is the punchline what light
bulb now what is it it only takes one
minimalist but first they have to ask
themselves does this add value I do have
a bit of a serious question though so
did you guys ever experience I've read a
lot of your material did you guys ever
experience any legal problems whenever
you were trying to embrace mentalism and
maybe downsize because housing codes are
something that I'm dealing with
currently and I'm interested in tiny
houses but Dallas is not very friendly
towards them and so I was wondering if
you guys have ever experienced that
problem and if there was a workaround or
if you have any ideas I've not
experienced it personally but I do have
a few ideas so I don't live in a tiny
home you know that's what we interviewed
a bunch of different perspectives here
whether it was Tami or Jay or Frank you
know in terms of the housing segment of
this or even Joshua Becker and his
family in the suburbs in a relatively
larger house but but you have several
people of the tiny homes I would urge
you to reach out to Jay Austin
he was just in our DC screening a few
days ago and he has a bunch of resources
and a bunch of ways to get around codes
and he has dealt a lot with with a lot
of the legality behind it especially in
DC they weren't very friendly with his
community and they had to they had to do
some really strange workarounds for some
of the stuff they did and what I'll tell
you is that I know that as this week
this trend becomes less of a trend and
more of a permanent fixture in our lives
I stayed in a container house about
three or four weeks ago in the middle of
nowhere in Montana it was and it was
awesome I had never been in a container
house before it was bigger than a tiny
home but but smaller than a regular home
but they're they're sort of customizable
you could fit four or five containers
together and all of a sudden you've got
a three-bedroom container home
and when I hear when I first heard
container home I'm like well that's that
that seems awful but it was this
architect who made it and it was one of
the most gorgeous houses I've ever
stayed in I mean the aesthetics the
attention to detail everything was
beautiful
and because it was a smaller space it
was very well curated and and you could
tell that he had put a lot of effort
thought attention into every square foot
of that space so no I don't have any
particular resources for you but that's
why I put some people in here I think J
because he is a tiny house designer hehe
and he is he's helped a bunch of people
on this journey I think he'd be a great
place to start
thank you appreciate it
howdy hi my name is Shannon you guys
helped me a lot I'm downsize about 90%
of my things just wanted to tell the
lady who was asking about downsizing how
to do it
if you get a friend who really loves you
they will help you because they will
tell you like it is and they will help
you throw it away it's way easier to get
rid of other people's [ __ ] isn't it oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah so I've already
downsized so I have a two-part question
one is how do you get over the I want to
say the grinding mentality when you're
young you know once she started to
embrace minimalism it's like everybody
around you is like you you it like you
have to be working for something you
have to be you know how do you get rid
of that and also secondly how do you
once you become a minimalist you know
it's less time taking care of things and
less TV and everything like that
what do you replace it with like how do
you know what you love because you've
been trained to do something or work or
your time to be managed by other people
how do you really take control of it so
the first part about the people around
you who dictate a particular set of
priorities the the rat-race
as it's called right the problem with
the rat race is if you win you're still
a rat
yeah I'll tell you the best advice I can
give you is a short platitude you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the people around you so you
shouldn't try to change the people in
your life what I found that is that I
worked with some good people but their
their values weren't the same as mine
and that's okay we're all different and
now you know six seven years after after
stumbling across this minimalism thing I
have surrounded myself with people who
have similar values to me it doesn't
mean we're the same types of people we
have different beliefs I mean even if
you look at just me and Ryan we've been
best friends for 25 years but we we
certainly don't believe the same
thoughts on on religion we don't believe
the same thoughts on politics we're
definitely voting for different people
there we have different beliefs right we
even have different personalities if you
put us on a myers-briggs personality
test
we are literally exact opposites but the
key to our friendship the key to our
relationship is that we share similar
values and so I would find people who
have similar values to you and to get
there you first got to figure out what
are my values and minimalism was the
step for me that got that stuff out of
the way to figure out what what those
values were yeah speaking to you know
what do i what do I do with my time now
I mean now I have way more time -
[Music]
especially in Montana like just I mean I
could not pick up enough hobbies like
it's just there's so many things to do
out there which you know sidenote like
it takes everything I have to not go out
and buy like a fly fishing pole and all
the accoutrements that come with that
but I already snowboard I already
mountain bike those are like my - like
big hobbies that I have in Montana
so my girlfriend also does those two
things so that that's that's what I do
like when I have time which you know I
would love to say that you know now that
I'm a minimalist I have all the free
time in the world like I still work
really really hard we are on this tour
right now we did 100 City tour in 2014
so I still
work really really hard but but when I
do have that extra time those are kind
of the things that I go to is how can i
how can I either get fit some way like I
will try to stay active on a daily basis
whether it's going to the gym or
mountain biking or going for a walk I
mean there are mountains all around this
so we will go out and do that but but
ultimately I guess it's just my really
long-winded way of saying that I will
focus on cultivating different passions
that I have that have nothing to do with
an end game that has nothing to do with
a result of well I'm going to you know
write this book or I'm going to affect
this many people's lives I mean
sometimes I do need to veg out and and
that's kind of my way of edging out I
still will you know catch up on a season
of this or that you know if time allows
it and it's something that me and my
girlfriend really want to do but
ultimately that's that's what I'm doing
with my extra time is kind of
cultivating cultivating the passions
that I have I will say I learned I
learned this throughout this whole
experience that this philosophy or the
saying I guess that is propagated
throughout our society of you know if
you find something that you really
really love to do you don't work a day
in your life and I really bought into
that even like when I started to we
started to get a lot of traction with
the minimalist I'm like oh wow we could
like write a book and maybe you know
make make it a meager living off of that
and and I don't have to go and get you
know a 40-hour a week job maybe I can
focus on this because I was really
passionate about it but that that that's
saying is kind of BS honestly I think
there are people out there who certainly
can say yes I do what I love and I don't
work a day in my life but I don't think
that is a realistic expectation for
every single person on this planet
I still work really really hard the
difference is now that work that I do
when I put in you know a 50 or 60 hour
work week the results that I get is much
more meaningful than you know when I was
training my guys to show their guys how
to sell cell phones to to little kids
Shawn's giving me the wrap-up back there
so we're gonna do we're gonna do a
lightning round this is so on our
podcast we do like the social media
lightning round things so if you can do
a verbal tweet to us that would be
awesome that way we can make sure we
answer all of your questions that for
everyone who is still in line we want to
make sure we get to it so come on up and
that's your question are you do you feel
the need to
yeah I think you don't ever get there I
wish it was here's your list of 100
items you can own and then you'll be
happy because that would be easy but the
truth is it's like a horizon and so my
34 year old self is different from my 29
year old self when I first found
minimalism I guess I was 28 when I first
found minimalism and so my needs are
different and so what minimalism looks
like to me now especially as being a
parent by proxy my needs look different
from even what there were a few years
ago and I'm constantly changing that so
I'm always looking toward that new
horizon and once I get to the horizon
the beautiful thing is there's always
going to be a new horizon so you won't
ever get there because once you get
there you have somewhere else you're
going thank you thank you and I have in
regards to the question earlier about
local resources for donating
there's Mission Arlington and Union
Gospel Mission in Fort Worth but I do
have a question my husband and I are
very passionate about traveling we just
went came back from California this
weekend and we want to know if you have
if you've written any essays or have any
trips for minimizing cost and stress
that's involved with traveling um you
know when I first was introduced to
minimalism : right the guy in the film
was the first video that I saw and I
have
ever wanted to like be that peripatetic
writer that Colin is but I really
respected the fact that he used
minimalism to kind of do that
um I don't hadn't written anything on
traveling and and you know minimizing
the cost but I would I will tell you
that there are a lot of good resources
out there so there's one guy his name is
Matt kepner's he goes by nomadic Matt he
has a book it's called how to travel the
world on $50 a day
there is Colin right exile lifestyle
calm he does a great job of talking
about his travels and kind of how he's
able to travel on a tight budget and has
some good tips there is there anything
else you can think of he also has a book
called how to travel full time and I
would recommend both of those as great
resources how to travel on $50 a day and
and then how to having a full time and
then also I would just talk to other
people about don't confuse travel with
vacation there are two separate things
and I think quite often we get confused
and think we have to every time we go
somewhere be on vacation that's usually
not the most economical way to travel
actually you know what I will tell you
we did that first year when we toured
with this is not very letting around I'm
sorry when we travelled with minimalism
live a meaningful life I made less money
that year then I had made since I was
like 18 years old I traveled more that
year then the entire 28 years of my life
building up to that and the way we did
that was it was a lot of sacrifices I
mean we slept on hardwood floors
we slept in our car we you know were in
Roach Motels
we we found ways like that so I mean
there are definitely ways that I can
recommend that you're like nudging me
yeah there are definitely ways that I
could recommend that I've done
personally I don't know if that's the
type of sacrifices you and your husband
want to make but certainly a few ideas
right there as well you don't have to
make those sacrifices by the way that
was just a way for us to get out and
spread the word there there are plenty
of resources out there that allow you to
travel on a very low budget for sure
thank you thank you we'll keep the
lightening round going my name is if a
live with her she came up with morals
for more in support because you nervous
okay so my question is how do you
differentiate like junk from not junk
because my biggest problem is I just
like throw everything away but I know
that's not the best thing to do so like
how do you know like what to throw away
and what to donate cents yeah for me I I
have a it's like a one-year rule and I
guess it's more of a six-month rule but
I'll think to myself like six lay a look
at um oh well my junk drawer gets full
for example I still have a junk drawer
and it will start to overflow so instead
of like coming up with a second drunk
drawer like I used to do like oh this
one's empty able to start putting stuff
in here I will start to go through and
be like okay when's the last time I use
this you know a little cable like what
does a cable even go to okay I know I
haven't used this in the last six months
I will probably not use it the next six
months
and and I will I will get rid of it but
but typically if I do put something in
that junk drawer it is something I think
I am going to to use but like Josh said
you know minimalism is a constant
evolving thing so something that I think
is gonna add value tomorrow or in the
next six months it may or may not I have
to constantly be asking those those
questions to myself yeah doesn't serve a
purpose of bring me joy and if not I let
go of it and I'll ask is it gonna serve
a purpose of someone else's life and if
it does that I'll find a way to donate
it I usually find an aggregator to do
that like goodwill or donation warehouse
or a place like that so I don't have to
go find the individual person and this
is something big that I can sell
Beck and I sold a kitchen table recently
on Craigslist we've got 25 bucks for it
anything that was a way I knew that
could add value to someone else's life
now there are some things where you know
Ella's artwork or something I'm not
gonna be able to donate that and so you
know we will get responsibly if we can
otherwise you know I'm not about living
a zero-waste lifestyle I'm about living
a considerably reduced waste lifestyle
and occasion I'll have to throw things
out but it's appreciably less than then
if I'm just doing it willy-nilly thank
you thank you Jim thanks for giving her
support
what's up guys howdy I would say great
movie thank you I have to give a
shout-out to my mom she drove all the
way from Arizona to see me and thank you
so you've talked a lot about consumers
what they can do differently what do you
think big business corporations small
business what do you think when money
becomes the opportunity cost like that's
what businesses need to start doing I
mean you look at a you know you look at
a Tim Cook who took over Apple and it
wasn't like hey how can we make an
awesome product for our customers it was
like all right how can we milk this
thing I mean that's what I felt like at
least and they just started
mass-producing you know a bunch of
different stuff and now for the first
time in Apple's history they are well
they're history but in the last you know
decade or so since they've really kind
of been booming they are now reporting a
loss in sales because they were putting
the money first you know for us now you
know people are first like that is that
is what that is what we do and that is
what I certainly would encourage
corporations to do in fact you know I
will go way out of my way to support
corporations that do that or small
independent businesses that do that I
think they set a really good example of
that you know if I go to a you know
really good coffee shop I can you know I
know when I walk in there how dedicated
how passionate those Brisas are or the
owner of that coffee shop is and and
that I can tell they are putting their
putting their passion first and they are
also creating an outstanding customer
experience and I can tell that money is
not their their driver and I think that
is where we have to start shifting
eventually that's where businesses
should start shifting eventually because
if they keep going after the money
I mean we're gonna we're going down the
same road we're gonna continue go down
the same road we are now which is again
it's eventually gonna we're gonna use
all these resources and not have
anything left
yeah we just say invest in people it
really that's what it comes down to and
we've been fortunate this
has grown way more than we ever
anticipated and it hasn't allowed us to
go out and rent Ferraris or anything
it's allowed us to invest in a a small
team of people whether it's Sean or or
Jessica who who helps out with our
social media or Sarah who helps out of
our PR stuff or any of the other folks
that are on our team we've been able to
help them grow in ways but but invest in
them as individuals whether that's
through interactions with them or
monetarily or whatever but but helping
them grow is my way to contribute so I
think small businesses are uniquely
positioned to do that because they're
gonna work closer with their team and
with their customers than any large
corporation ever will be able to thanks
a lot thank you I see one more we're
gonna cut it off here no more sneaking
in line but this is the last one I mean
my mom before she gives me this box of
stuff it's already got the sentimental
value attached how do you deal with
sentimental items in in 2008 my mother
moved from Dayton Ohio to st. Pete Beach
Florida to finally retire that's what
you do when you live in Ohio you move to
Florida and a few months after she moved
down there she found out she had lung
cancer and she's been the next year
going through chemo and radiation and I
spent a lot of time with her that year
as she was battling Stage four lung
cancer and eventually in 2009 she passed
and I had to make one last trip down to
Florida to deal with her stuff and so I
flew from Dayton Ohio down to st. Pete
Beach Florida
and when I got to her tiny one-bedroom
apartment I found about three apartments
worth of stuff crammed into her tiny
one-bedroom apartment and it's not like
she was a hoarder right there were no
dead cats in her freezer but she owned a
lot of stuff
she had 65 years with her accumulations
and I was going through all of it and I
found a bunch of stuff in her kitchen in
her living room and her bathroom was
stuffed with stuff and her linen closet
had just I mean it was brimming with
just towels and blankets and bedsheets
and all this stuff and then I got to her
her bedroom closet she had 14 winter
coats few of them still had tags on them
she lived in the st. Pete Beach and she
had 14 with their coats and so I did
what any good son would do I
I called u-haul and I rent to the
largest truck they had hold on to all
these sentimental items right and then I
invited some of her friends over to help
me deal with his stuff because there's
just too much stuff to go at it alone
and and so I called up a storage locker
because I couldn't commingle mom stuff
with my stuff I already had a big house
and a full basement full of stuff but a
storage locker yeah a storage locker
would let me hold on to everything just
in case I needed it someday and some
non-existent hypothetical future you
know just in case the three most
dangerous words in the English language
and so as I waited for the u-haul to
arrive I was packing up her stuff and I
found these four boxes under her bed
these old printer paper boxes they're
kind of heavy they were sealed with
excessive amounts of packing tape so I
pulled them out one by one I sort of
just stood there looking down at these
these four boxes I notice that each box
was labeled with just a numeral on the
top of each box just one
[Music]
two three four and I stood there and I
wondered what could possibly be in those
boxes and we're out of time folks I hope
you have a great night no it was my old
elementary school paperwork grades one
through four the all takes over the
crowd no and and so at first I'm opening
these boxes I'm like what the hell is
mom holding on to all the stupid
paperwork but then all these memories
came rushing back and I realized she was
holding on to all the memories that were
in the boxes right but then I thought to
myself wait a minute these boxes have
been sealed for more than two decades it
became clear to me in that moment the
mom didn't need to hold on to those
boxes to hold on to a piece of me I was
never inside those boxes but then I
looked around in her apartment I looked
around at all her stuff and I realized I
was getting ready to do the same thing
except instead of store her things
neatly in a box under my bed I was
getting ready to cram it all into a big
box with a padlock on it just in case so
I called up u-haul and I cancelled the
truck I spent the next 12 days selling
or donating almost everything and I
learned some pretty important lessons
along the way but most important I
learned that our memories aren't in our
things our memories are inside us and
they always will be and by letting go of
some of those things I could actually if
I wasn't gonna selfishly cling to those
things I would add value to other
people's lives by letting go of it
finding the stuff a new home and so
letting go not only freed me but helped
others and so realizing that it changed
everything for me when I got back home I
had to take an inventory of my own life
I realized that wow there was a lot I
could let go of here
[Applause]
Thanks thank you before we take off I
want to give a big thanks to all the
folks here at the theater thank you so
much for having us here tonight y'all
are awesome
let's give him a round of applause and I
think he snuck off but I'm still gonna
thank him anyway because hopefully this
will show up on the podcast crew Spence
was here tonight he is was in the
version of the film that didn't make it
here tonight but he'll also be in a lot
of the bonus content they were given out
to you all as well so he is a
relationship expert and he just did some
phenomenal work for the film it didn't
work in the final narrative but it was
it was just a great interview so we're
gonna be sending that to you all when
the online release comes out so well
well thank him as well if you're ok with
that thank you
[Applause]
and I also want to thank it's really
expensive for us to travel like this and
so we started a blog six years ago and
we couldn't even spell blog at the time
and there was a company called Bluehost
that has helped us along the way they
host our website for us now and they've
been really supportive of this movement
and they didn't ask for anything from us
but they offered to fund some of our
travels for this tour so I just want to
say thanks to Blue Hose they've been
awesome for us and most important I want
to thank you we're gonna be out there
afterward dishing out hugs now our hugs
have gotten much better than this we've
learned the art and the science of the
hug so make sure you come grab one like
I said they're books out there as well
if you want to pick one of those up
there pay whatever you want or just pick
one up if you didn't bring your wallet
with you that's totally okay and if you
leave here with one message tonight we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so tear your eye or two
[Music]